ouch hey hey I'm going after this ones
because she is the one more intense this
is hey hey here huh no no this is not
fear whatsoever look at the tail if they
were afraid that tell will be between
the leg this is just plain aggression
now the voice it's not frustrated you
know it's not very excited hey see the
touches at the moment I told you see
what happens that they'll goes down and
the head goes down that is the switch
from this to this hmm right so the brain
goes from dominance to relaxation that's
amazing cuz she's just stopped right so
that's what I'm saying she didn't fail
mm-hmm yeah I fail that's what we're
saying I failed I failed amazing look at
that it's very hard for you guys that's
why this dog should come to you already
program so I have she's she's flying
away from situation we don't want flying
away from situation she have to learn to
face situation so she learned okay when
I see him this is how I need to behave
this is more this submissive State
that's a submissive State look at that
so even with dogs grandparents have to
play leadership role there we go that's
better
this is her on her own
look copy behavior that's right there
should be peace okay to rehabilitate
little dogs seven pounds but most of the
people are moving away from seven pounds
so it's how you move how you behave in
front of aggression how you behave in
front of a spoiled little dog are you
gonna give him a space if you give me
space they take over all right can you
please knock on the door so the reality
is knows most of time people are sitting
down like playing the door
Hey there we go before you open the door
you got a claim if you don't have Lane
whatever you boast with it gonna be by
optical huh here's somebody's coming in
Shh Hey Hey so then they supposed to
come a smell no they can't climb on from
people mm-hmm that is excitement that is
dominance so did you get that you got to
claim the space and claim the Dhokla
yeah you can also use see use this hmm
you become a shepherd the Shepherds
don't use the stick to hit to hurt the
animal the shepherd use the stake to
create a boundary to create a line to
move forward see the difference but if
you move with the stake like this the
stake has no power
if you move with a stick like this this
thick has power have you seen the most
of the Emperor's carry stick yeah so can
you be a little more Empress yeah
hairier man you gonna be the new emperor
this place huh so Maggie your days of
being the boss are over